[Music]
I was just leaving hotel
[Music]
Constance has he said anything about
leaving he's our cousin
and he's decided to come visit us and
he'll go and he's ready my name is Mary
Katherine Blackwood the black woods have
always lived on his house and we will
never leave here no matter what they say
or what they do to us never
[Music]
father built this gate to keep us safe
but it could not protect him you and
confidence people here believe Constance
killed father one of the true genuine
mysteries of our time there is such a
thing as good taste you ever tasted us
what are you doing
I heard father in his room I feel him
coming back America it's our cousin
Charles black hood he looks just like
father
has he said anything about leaving he's
our cousin and he'll go in he's ready
his presence is a strange new spell we
have many plans today
[Music]
that chance my dead brother's chair
going to put death and all their food
and watch them die
he was a very wicked man our Father
the world is full of terrible people
[Music]
you